muchos estaban rezando en la mezquita de
la provincia de kunduz cuando una
explosión dejó decenas de muertos y
heridos la mayoría creyentes de la rama
chií del islam
mastrov otan que estaba ocupado en
trabajos de construcción en casa en
cuanto empezó el rezo llegó el sonido de
la explosión cuando fui a buscar a mis
familiares a la mezquita vi que estaba
llena de gente tirada el número aún no
está claro
el mono bajó de una moto 762 jump su
debutante que estaba cerca y lo que vi
fue como el fin del mundo porque les
pasa esto a los musulmanes qué religión
debemos adoptar donde no haya nada de
esto y esté prohibido matar a los
musulmanes créeme yo no puedo ni hablar
no puedo decirte cuántos cadáveres he
trasladado en mi coche
antes de dar una mala monta los
militantes suníes del grupo islámico
reivindicaron la autoría del atentado
tras una serie de ataques en las últimas
semanas en todo el país que el grupo
terrorista también se ha atribuido algo
que pone en jaque al gobierno talibán
del país que está enfrentando serias más
de seguridad y aseguró ya está
investigando los hechos esta tarde se
produjo una explosión en una mezquita de
nuestros compatriotas chiítas en el
distrito de khanabad bandar varios de
nuestros compatriotas fueron
martirizados y heridos mandamos una
unidad especial y estamos investigando
afganistán está sumida en una profunda
crisis económica sanitaria y política
algo que se suma a la reciente oleada de
atentados y violencia